voici le nouveau smartphone pliant
Xiaomi c'est le mix fold 2 gros avantage
qu'il a par rapport au Samsung Galaxy Z
fold II c'est que vous avez un vraiment
très très grand écran qui est super
agréable et super confortable alors
petit truc c'est qu'ici il va être
légèrement incurvé ça crée vraiment une
espèce d'asymétrie avec d'un côté
quelque chose d'incurvé et de l'autre
côté on les absolument pas vous
retrouver un énorme écran intérieur et
je sais pas si ça vous saute aux yeux
mais par rapport à Samsung vous n'avez
pas ici de caméra pas de caméra sur
l'écran il y a rien alors si vous venez
de très très près que vous regardez là
on va pouvoir deviner ici un tout petit
capteur à la différence de Samsung où
vous prenez et vous devez accompagner
l'ouverture de votre charnière et vous
pouvez l'arrêter où vous voulez ici chez
Xiaomi dès que vous arrivez à mi-course
il souffre tout seul l'idée ici c'est
qu'on est deux systèmes soit ouvert soit
fermé et surtout ce smartphone il a un
truc pour lui c'est qu'il est
extrêmement fin un design que j'aime
bien qui rappelle vraiment effectivement
tous les design qu'on a aujourd'hui chez
Xiaomi un partenariat avec Leica au
niveau de la photo il y a un côté
extrêmement premium je trouve très beau
très bien fait très bien fini très
classe comment est-ce que vous le
trouvez ce smartphone est-ce que vous le
trouve intéressant ce qui pourrait vous
avec dites-moi tout ça dans les
commentaires et pour plus d'actu sur la
tech et bien pensez à vous